Reggie taught me a new to gallog phrase.
He said,
it's really a romantic Malita anti Tiko.
Reggie
Mugu done Gabi sign,
young La Hat Nakita [inaudible] video
called [inaudible] that long lingo.
Now a whole Naga other man,
tagalog a tiller must matter long na or
mud,
the Gallo [inaudible] case,
a nerd pedal my heat up.
But in and Tagalog,
Panasonic in Nyanga loose talk Kong
Macapagal subs.
Uh,
suburban at Lingo Valentine's Day on
home.
Uh,
Ditto saw her palm,
uh,
beanie again and Manga air non chocolate
chocolate day.
And Monga lucky [inaudible] Kumar
[inaudible] took a lot day at mass
matter Bajo Neon,
uh,
k the home mcgee [inaudible] at the
middle and a home.
Uh,
Morgan Dung.
Belita Emilia Hornung Canada.
Now Gopro k,
uh,
Gaga meeting Ito [inaudible] Pilipinas.
So he sang lingual knock up our lead
dunk,
a non Canada pedal,
uh,
Melinda and video only door k a messiah
hall.
Uh,
it's uh,
nappy glock or subject Kish.
Uncle or Sergei.
Yeah.
All right.
That's just another little sample of my
progress and to gallog how it's going.
Um,
uh,
obviously I'm not fluent.
I can express myself about simple
things.
I could make simple sentences,
I can communicate about basic things
with basic vocab,
but for three weeks in I'm pretty happy
with how things are going.
Um,
I'm looking forward to my trip to
Philippines next week and I'll try out
my to gallog they're more and practice
more and I'm going to study while I'm
there and hopefully that will expand my
ability even more.
Tagalog is an interesting experience.
The only other thing I can compare it to
is when I started studying Japanese way
back in the beginning years and years
ago,
because before that I had only studied
languages that were much more similar to
English.
Like I had studied French in school,
I had studied Hebrew and modern Hebrew
kind of has syntax that's similar to
English.
Like the word order is different from
biblical Hebrew.
It's more like English.
So when I started learning Japanese,
the word order and the grammar and
sentence structure,
something completely different.
It kind of was difficult at first and
freaked me out a bit.
Like,
because I had to think in a whole new
way and piece together.
The ideas to make sentences in a
completely new way.
It couldn't just change out the words
like you can in some other languages.
And now Tagalog is kind of similar to
that.
Similar to the old days when I started
Japanese and I was freaking out about
this completely new way of expressing
myself and to Gal looks Kinda like that,
that you can't just change the words out
into a tagalog words.
You can't just take an English sentence
and change the words and to,
to Gallog it won't happen,
won't,
you won't be able to express yourself
like that at all.
No one would understand that.
Totally different experience.
So that's quite fun.
Quite interesting to do that.
It's quite mind bending and it makes me
think in new ways and I always enjoy
that.
So yeah,
that's another look at how it's going.
I hope you are busy studying too and
improving at whatever language you're
focused on.
Good night.